la disparatada comedia en la que la
propietaria de una lavandería se ve
inmersa en mundos paralelos ganó siete
estatuillas incluyendo mejor película y
mejor actriz para Michelle durante la
edición número 95 de los premios Oscar
celebrada en Los Ángeles
para todos los niños y niñas pequeños
que me están viendo esta noche y se
parecen a mí
[Aplausos]
Este es un faro de esperanza y
posibilidad
es una prueba de que los sueños son
grandes y que se hacen realidad
tras años en el olvido mediático brendan
Fraser fue Coronado como mejor actor por
su sensible actuación en la ballena
luego de haber revelado ser víctima de
agresión sexual hace más de 20 años
durante el movimiento mitú
Alemania se llevó el galardón a mejor
película internacional con sin novedad
en el frente una adaptación de la novela
de Erick María remarc desarrollada
durante la Primera Guerra Mundial y que
cuenta los horrores de las trincheras a
través de un combatiente y la guerra
siguió presente con la obra de cien en
films y hbo Max naval ni premiada como
mejor documental
hay alguien que no pudo estar con
nosotros esta noche
el líder de la oposición rusa sometido a
prisión solitaria a causa de cito
textualmente la guerra de agresión
injusta a Ucrania de Vladimir Putin
su esposa Julia y su hija daria
asistieron a la ceremonia y junto con
los realizadores de la película
recibieron el premio una velada que fue
suficiente para olvidar la bofetada
propinada por el actor Will Smith al
humorista Chris Rock hace un año en el
mismo escenario